yeah I think we will just have like a
tiny World Cup like a World Cup video no
so this this was actually a very very
good game
and like actually
is great in many
types and so on but
playing such a game we haven't seen him
doing a long long long ever
time
okay so they came from some I don't know
Khan system but very soon they are into
some versions of basically schweningen
everything looks logical reasonable
simple
and just in general I I always think
it's
black supports obviously to be okay
I mean you know if it's not okay then
because power would barely make it to a
Grandmaster and not the world champion
because they always play those but I
don't know if I somehow I found those
systems not so easy
especially with the bishop on D3 because
white have just easy threads Okay so
Queen H3 so what is white straight right
now
quite simple white white wants to play
E5
take te take take take on F6 checkmate
so this was played now a question
actually is E5 possible or not
because I remember I was looking at this
and I wasn't certain why not to play
five I think actually E5 is a decent
move
but what what is the best line that you
think
we should look at after E5
yeah
no we're talking but this is nothing for
it that's horrible for life
yeah but but but but take take take
Bishop F4
this is what this is how he wants to
play
yeah and then I was thinking this is
absolutely the way the game should
continue
and these are now playing this move
and keeping tons of squares like tons
casparov actually had some games with
different
same material sacrifices they were also
Queens on the boat but really so many
squares are being under control and
black has basically four against two
probably this is okay for black like
very like really okay for like okay two
super strong players didn't go into it
so
Bishop D2 Bishop D4 they are both
possible
okay but here amazing amazing action
stuffs I mean black is probably have to
play D5 right I mean because this is
this is no joke this E5 thread
okay here incredible
F5
I mean if black okay I mean what what
else if not F5 here
I mean the thing is that after capture
D2 is kind of hanging in many lines and
so this
this is serious dude
he's not not joking here
yeah if take on F5 Queen taken F7 seems
to be hanging
take on D2
take on E6
okay so this is somewhat checkmate
and this is also out there so basically
you have to protect the H7 scroll
came back
thank you
now actually very interesting
what do we have
Black Knight okay I think Kansky agree
with that
but now the question how to take the
Knight how to take it
okay so what you're saying maybe that
you want okay the question is night the
night will take of course but then would
you want to take it with the bishop or
with the Rook they will so basically
what you are saying that's super
important is that you much prefer to
keep
this one
then this one
okay
you see Kansas
we all agree everyone's happy
but they're going to take only four
this we don't agree
take
this is excellent excellent way of
thinking I mean perfect because you're
first of all you're threatening
Checkmate take take and walk H4 so you
are looking at the most false line no
joke that's perfect
and this
also probably looks like Checkmate right
I mean what to do
Checkmate this way or another
okay maybe this possible but okay this
analyze it another day but but
this is very very basic idea we see
those ideas actually there are some
lines in Sicilian that those are
this is just Elementary idea
Queen take
and actually here this is super strong
move
just hitting many many things black is
better here
I mean white pawns look super impressive
but they are actually weak they are
going nowhere black king is extremely
close
white king is weak on H1
and the B2 Pawn is weak
so this is actually
very very bad for white but the idea is
perfect so you know this is something
always always worth remembering
you know to play some to play a great
combination or just to play something
white there has there have to be two
steps you have to get the right idea if
not it's just coincidence but then you
have to get the right way to play it
no this this game comes to Australia
fire
you play this move
yeah this is a big move
basically his idea is quite funny that
if the bishop take
he blocked The Rock
the bishop you said you're very correct
the bishop is the most important piece
so by playing Knight takes D5 he
defended the bishop on D3
well that's why he's there
yeah because all other lines are
actually it's actually white can be
really worse there
any food take okay now just resigning
so you play this way
of course the the who cannot be touched
okay black is pretty much only one move
to play here
which one
eight six
which one sorry
this one
okay I'll go here
right
why why in let's think together
okay we we see the threat right take and
checkmate
but why white six I mean just an
instinct and you know we spoke before
about instincts in some other games and
what we would play quite quickly
leaving the white is attacking on the
light squares
so making creating even more weaknesses
seems like kind of uncomfortable G6
G6 yes G6 was played
for
now actually really really interesting
position
first of all what is the threat by white
Bishop take G6 okay so we will we will
sit on this position actually I was
thinking maybe we'll see the
Nakamura game but maybe we'll just look
at that depends how deep we want to look
at that well depends on you if you will
throw the move super quickly we'll go
ahead if not make it slower
which moves candy that moves black hairs
in this position this is really
important because this is really
complicated position really complicated
position so first let's start we all
know Bishop takes G6 is the threat okay
what possible moves should black be
considering here
which one
King G7
Queen C6 very good
King G7 was played in the game
Queen C6 good move and
green takes E5 I mean yeah there's a
pawn there it's important
I mean we will just touch J lines
lightly Queen takes E5 Bishop take
kinda has to go there
back now only move that allows black
survival here
which is the only move that allow black
thumb survival in this position
I'll take
okay I can tell you this you'll survive
for a few more moves but for certain
blood you'll die so
it's not that exciting
look f8 and if I will play okay question
what is okay well what is white thread
no no what is white thread we have to it
doesn't matter if we are 2800 2700 1500
2 000 doesn't matter we think the same
way
basically very simple Queen take eight
seven Checkmate Queen G7 defended seven
attack the queen you know we think that
the more stupid that we look at the
position the better we we are thinking
right
it's really really that way remember
the Chinese kid maybe maybe we'll be
world champion but you know what we just
see we most of us would have played
rookie six attacking the Knight on E7
and defending E4
he played C6 you know one day he's gonna
laugh at us with his 28 plus 100 but
simple simple simple Checkmate on H7
what prevent Checkmate Queen attack the
queen so look before winning so okay
fate I play hook G4
so how to how black survive here
I take
eight six yeah like you know with the
code really but yes yeah I mean that's
what if not it's Checkmate know what to
do
I mean H6 and actually not so clear
because Rook G4 also there is Bishop G5
some Outpost
you know this is the thing that it's
like it's we are not like eight six like
it doesn't feel so happy playing this
move but the the other alternative is
just death so it's like you know
right so this is one line which is
actually possible to play I think
Queen C6 is
a very decent move
it constantly keeps some some eye on the
G2
and
on
G6 there was some line
I'm saying like this I thought was
interesting Rook F6
and if you take take
this is something to
to be looking seriously this line is
better for white
actually possible here to take also
actually interesting to bring the king
I mean with such such a bishop that's
defending everything
I mean white is better no no doubt
because he has he has two pawns okay I'm
not under the illusion that white will
be able to keep his two connected pawns
if you will keep these two connected
pawns it will be over but even if it
just gives the E5 get his King to the
center and trade those ones
no white is better here although it
wasn't that clearly decisive
so Queen C6 Rook F6 is a possibility at
least worth considering
probably not a bad one
this this this one is a critical line
but I remember it was okay for
okay for black
maybe the line we've seen But White
seems better the queen takes E5 is one
straight line
with Queen G7 and H6
my middle played King G7
it actually proved to be a bit wrong
move
Caskey played E6 this is the the move
that either Queen takes E5 is not
allowing or queen C6 Queen B6 not alone
okay what is the threat by white here
and then take one f8
excellent so you want to play f8 and
then just put Rook F7 so pretty fast
pretty first movies rookie f8 because if
the bishop for example moves I don't
know
this seems like Checkmate and I just
sacrifice here just has to hit the spot
something like that
so who can fate now now came really
amazing play by kamsky
I mean okay where where can he attack
black
how can he attack black
I mean black needs one move I think if
black plays Queen E5 actually Black's
winning Maybe
I'm not certain but to me just super
quickly looking at the position if Queen
E5 is being played black is just winning
E6 is falling and
that's it
Queen E3
right right Queen E3 so Queen D4 is
pretty much
pretty much winning right I mean how do
you want to win let's say black plays
this beautiful movie five play check
here check everything first check check
check check check
something like this looks not bad right
okay so we understand the threat no it's
very important so he has a false thread
okay that's a start
Bishop C5 okay apparently this mama Del
has doesn't like to be checkmated
go figure
okay now what
Queenie one
apparently he wants to check my team
Bishop D6
actually I think Bishop D6 is losing on
the spot it is losing on the spot what
to play after Bishop E7 and actually I
I'm more asking than saying because I
have no clue
well I want to play after Bishop E7
C4
yeah this I was thinking
C4 Pawn takes C4
kinda have to play that Queen C3 King H6
but where is the Checkmate there
hmm
something like
Bishop C4 but but I'll just take it no
I'm not certain if there is an immediate
win in this position
I I think Bishop E7 was crucial to play
bottom line I mean I I don't see
absolutely an immediate when maybe there
is but
Bishop D6 was played
this is the big thing that is
surrendered there
days four square
yeah just just just just one everyone
just want to run an engine for a second
because we I mean C4 looks dangerous
after Bishop okay first of all yeah
okay so we Bishop E7 C4 take exactly our
line okay that was not bad
okay we'll go home today be happy
okay perfect exactly our line this this
okay here
C4 only move
we okay take check
this okay this we will here
take take we will heal
exactly Queen D6 only move right we will
exactly here
yes and here we mentioned hook C6 or
something okay computer plus one maybe
Houdini or whatever is stronger but
that's what I said you know the reason
why I called him for help
I couldn't get more like I think I
wanted well I don't want to be actually
any color white is a piece down and
black has horrible position so just
leave me alone but it wasn't it wasn't
really clear
by the way once again looking at the
time
I mean okay it's quite interesting that
he played Bishop D6 and got more than 30
seconds but I've apparently played it
really really fast
apparently he played it really really
fast and controlling the h4s we actually
was not you know forecast key with
seven minutes to play C4 Queen C3 his
King is weak
plus one no okay maybe I mean it's no
clear at all
but he replayed just what's the threat
here
who take a seven King tape
King G7
perfect
so now we play this move but now but now
really really a great move I mean this
this was really beautiful really really
beautiful game
but the Rook
here yeah but I take the Rook The Rook
is under attack
23 right
what's the difference
that you're gonna have Queen default
check right yeah
exactly okay played H5 I mean take
check
same story we've been all along it's
just like it's kind of interesting how
it moved here moved there then he came
back to E3
that Bishop on the third Square Bishops
yeah exactly
so you played H5 and oh okay we also
discussed the amazingly like I haven't
I I've seen the game and not just it was
beautiful I haven't really analyzed
analyze it actually now first time when
we stopped at Bishop D6 Bishop E7 that's
why I wasn't clear but amazing blunder
in normal media with such a
you know I guess those really amazing
players that so fast so creative so this
sometimes the tiny details may be what's
eating them I mean there over there even
sometimes somewhat same style
Super Creative super energetic I mean
those are not amazing details for 24
best players in the world
all right how does white finish the game
here
windy forking it takes
yeah we'll takes H5 immediately I mean
okay this is how the game went and
resign this is kind of checkmate
and
yeah and here
take or queen G7 is checkmate
all right we will give few minutes to
Nakamura game today just thinking
quickly I mean some amazing the game
Kawana tomashevsky
tomato sauce Checkmate in seven most
Miss winning the queen missed
unbelievable what he didn't miss there
and was out even Too Close losing to
cram it was a bit Yeah a bit yuck like
big one right Kobe is the at least so
far
no it's a very strong player but
okay
we can go and see
so basically kind of invitation to play
the sharp Marshall
but it was a very solid game so we will
just see this game
quite quickly actually this is the
interesting idea
the main purpose is
if black will take with the c pawn it is
worse Black really wants to take with
the
E Pawn but to do that after playing
Knight D7 kind of interesting play
by the way G4 immediately
I I think sorry F5 I think G4 is a
decent continuation for white I think
that's how they play
at least one of the ways how they play
I think I think it's a decent one maybe
this explains why Carol first played
this and now F5
and now since black want to take and you
cannot take with the e-pawn play this
Knight H6
okay
and now you can play G6 and pretend he's
playing checkers or something but
all right Queen F6 Bishop E2
sting move I didn't why he played Bishop
B2
huh
I mean it could not have been so scared
about this move
hmm
maybe indeed he wants if take to be able
to play no but I'm not certain about
this move Bishop P2
oh well I'm gonna let it let them play
that okay that's where we want to go
okay they play this position
and it's really interesting because
black has this weakness white as those
kind of looks like
nicer a bit for white but
no this Dojo position that Nakamura
played very plays very very well
but actually This Global okay played
also well
it was kind of funny to see the the
press conference him in the press
conference like okay his English is okay
but nothing more and like and he was
asked if he's happy that okay he's gonna
play kramnik and he said wow you know
it's such a big difficult thing and he's
like very like so much stress and you
know and Susan was asking well but it's
better that you are playing kramnik than
being on your way home tomorrow he said
well not clear
like I don't know that was like I mean
maybe this is like Lost in Translation
two or something like couldn't
understand it logic but it's like
okay so apparently prefers I don't know
no it says like not clear
okay yeah why why didn't take the pawn
is it possible to take the I think this
is what
in just some positional pressure like
taking E5 C5 this this one
now in all those positions you know I
always get this bishop out whatever
wherever and you'll be okay
which is exactly what
Nakamura never got to do in this game
never here you go C5 Big Move
big big move against this beautiful
Bishop
no but this this is not pretty by any
any standards this is not pretty
yeah probably he had to take the the
pawn on E5
once again like being
you know many times like being the super
extra is what sometimes hurt them
yeah so I mean just again we are not
there were no big huge blunders actually
it was just squeezed here which is okay
really you go home and you say well what
to do
exactly it's like not blundering also I
mean this bishop on B7
Rook C8 rookie one
yeah this is very pretty move
the bishop is aiming for this diagonal
and actually black king can be under
attack
ing can be under attacking
okay H4 very good right I mean
what to play in this position
for white
and therefore
but I can also take on D4 I can take on
F or D4
I mean basically basically giving pawns
may be great but first question is why
I mean
no I mean if it's great okay but but why
you know I always say
you don't want to take a pawn you want
to give a pawn perfect just have a good
reason why
I I'm not certain why to actually why to
give any of those preferably the F4 is
really questionable
take
take the night
I mean okay if black can do this tiny I
don't know get the bishop to D5
it's a bit different world
but no this
is just really really bad
well I'm sorry
it keeps the effect
it's basically very simple no it's just
to keep the Pawns
just just no no night 84 no night 84 no
Bishop take it for very simple we just
want to keep our material and take the
opponents
yeah I mean and this bishop is
no actually this one's not so bad no
this is horrible position
actually here I think I think this was
winning even
actually was it Bishop C3 there was some
continuation here that was winning much
faster with ideas of D5 I think it was a
debt at this moment but
yeah you know again the difference
between human and computer and I'm not
even
uncertain about if it was exactly here I
think it was but you know such a strong
player with white
almost no chance that any any player you
know maybe because Bob or something like
this but even Carson like I I don't see
him playing D5 they just understand that
black is in horrible spot they'll just
squeeze one minute okay why why to do
anything unnecessary
okay and he won the game like take take
just very very straightforward here
yeah the hook is under attack
if okay two
I guess just hear and take is what
also in deadline right yeah that's
that's one possibility right probably
better
and here yeah at the beginning I was
looking at this but exactly exactly this
line I mean just this beautiful Bishop
is going to be gone
and D5 yes this one yeah Nakamura was
shaking and doing the usual things like
like
the the usual disbelief how could this
be that he had lost the game the world
is not okay but
okay definitely after September 20 okay
definitely
said okay
all right so so put him first on air
all right yeah but just over
just back and
before whatever
so that was it for
very much shaking his heady cow in this
tournament but actually I was I thought
he played the best chess up until this
match I thought really
uh
who would my the people someone was
asking me like if I probably had to
choose I don't even remember how they go
by public ramnik just because even if he
doesn't play strong chess it's just like
no it's like such a heavy weight you
know it does it doesn't really have to
punch like just to be there you know so
Chronicles
apparently I'm left with one but I but I
haven't placed any bats yet so that was
good you know I made all all possible
mistaking predictions of the players
other than one but no bad so they'll
still get still give some hope
thank you